clàudia Roden hey David now that you're
an older millennial are there cultural
references in today's college students
that today's college students don't
understand are you noticing it more now
that you teach college there's a couple
that I can think of one is Seinfeld
references yes like for me
Seinfeld any Seinfeld reference among
friends I immediately identify because I
know every episode back and forth there
is a new generation now that might be
familiar with Seinfeld because they've
gotten the DVDs or they've figured out
that it's an interesting thing to watch
Hulu now oh it is not who I didn't know
that but by and large the the
generations that understand Seinfeld
references are older now than the kids
that are in college I'm actually going
through every single episode of Seinfeld
right now and there are two reasons for
that one is because I like the show
you're funny but the other reason is so
that I can just understand the
references that you make on the show and
right at me I have to be able to be like
oh yeah I pick up that reference you put
it right on that is going to be better
able to pretend to understand the
Seinfeld references as soon as he's done
with those 180 episodes where are you
what season are you on season five okay
so that's aren't there seven total maybe
nine and I didn't realize that they
don't standalone entirely like one
Episode goes into the next and they they
will bring up like prior references yes
that happened in past episode that's
true absolutely true the concept of this
is not so much college students but I
was talking to a bunch of teenagers the
other day who are roughly my sister's
age and they mentioned seeing this thing
that was flat and you could put
headphones and a CD into it and I said
yeah that's called the discman that
that's how people listen to music when I
was your age and even knowledge of
portable CD players is starting to
recede probably not in college students
but in high school students at this
point which is shocking to me because I
remember when we still had I I'm
sounding like that the old guy yelling
get off my lawn I remember when we still
had cassette tapes and you had a Sony
Walkman nevermind the Sony discman yeah
I think actually a startling percentage
of Millennials think that $2 bills are
fake oh yeah that's another actually
read about that
the Internet dial-up noise that used to
happen when you dialed into AOL and your
modem made a series of screeches that
might even be beyond your to beyond my
time yet so do you as far as you
remember have you always had like
high-speed Internet well it was very
very slow yeah I remember my mom would
load a website and then she'd make
coffee in the meantime by the time she
was done making coffee she would sit
back down at the computer oh that sounds
like dial-up that but maybe you just
weren't around when the connection I
think I'd remember that screeching noise
yeah I do understand that reference yeah
I think uh more and more college
students don't know what's going on but
you know what when I taught at Boston
College this past semester I really
didn't feel that out of touch with the
students I really didn't I I felt like I
was in touch with what was going on so
yeah I guess you should I mean you're
not that much older than them exactly
that's what I was telling myself that's
exactly right
okay oh and you know here's what another
one microfiche do you even know what
that is relative microfiche is you would
go to the library and you would want an
old record of a newspaper and you would
get these it's almost like a film like a
like a camera negative but it has like
an entire page of a newspaper on it or
multiple pages and you would put it
under a projector and magnifying glass
type device and move it around and it
would zoom in and you would look through
a lens almost like a microscope and you
could read old newspapers or magazines
that had been shrunk down significantly
for space that's cool and it shines a
light through it it's such antiquated
technology really and it that started to
be on its way out when I was in
elementary school yeah so this was for
back when the news was on print right I
mean now you can just go online oh yeah
TV that's exactly right
the Internet has it they've widened the
internet tubes and now you don't need a
microfiche anymore all right I hope I've
not aged myself embarrassingly but I'll
try to undo the damage on today's bonus
show